it's a lot of house hi I'm Garrett and
I'm Nikki we're fasting about how other
people live so we're gonna try and find
some really interesting living
situations and live they're experiencing
a totally different lifestyle to see
which one's will bring us closer
together or push us further apart
this week we're living in a mansion
finally the showers are so tall you're
gonna see it it's it's great this is it
okay you have your own cul-de-sac
hi thank you for having us
we used to pretty small things so this
is a very exciting we're pretty excited
I built this home in 2006 with the idea
in mind that we had four kids we wanted
our house to be the place where
everybody came together and kids can
enjoy having people over
that's so tall 24 foot ceiling many four
feet high that is lofty this is my
Richie Rich moment I don't know if ever
in my life I will afford my own mansion
but for this week I get to pretend to
this house is worth somewhere in the
neighborhood of three and a half to four
million dollars it's like the American
dream right I mean I'm really looking
forward to this I don't see a reason why
I wouldn't be this mansions got
everything 8400 square feet livable it's
on four and a half acres it's six
bedrooms six baths
oh my master suite indeed there's a
fireplace and a teeny Jacuzzi tubs on
the other side of the fireplace yeah yes
that's the deepest tub I've ever seen
hopefully one of these showers has got
like a rain what is it called there's
three showerheads you have the rain
showerhead and then you have the two
regular showerheads and you have a body
Jets can you turn them all on at the
same time you can that's I can't even
reach the showerhead that's never
happened before like you're gonna fall
like four feet before it even touches me
this is the formal living room look at
the fans Nicky the fans arms or fans
it's fan ception there are two
dishwashers three ovens a warming drawer
microwave you could be cooking three
turkeys at one time so we have a chef
coming to make us a fancy dinner because
I'm a fly in fancy lady this week and I
don't have to cook my own dinner this
man's gonna cook dinner for me this is
when you have fancy people over and you
want to impress them with your home
that's us now Nicky that's does it for
fancy laughs thanks John this is
now well there's a movie theater I
forgot there's a movie theater but you
can watch three different sporting
events at a time or three different
television shows at a time or you can
turn the video wall off and drop the
projector screen so upstairs we have the
game room Nikki which was easy you think
you're best at the highlight of the
house in my opinion is the outside the
outdoor area features a full sport court
and in-ground trampoline it is a very
bouncy trampoline I have three horseshoe
pits and playground area for the kids
house that's a casita yeah we asked for
a house I never have enough houses the
guest casita consists of the studio
apartment and a workout gym casitas
kitchens bigger than my kitchen the pool
also features waterfall and a waterslide
I am treating this like a mini vacation
I'm gonna sit by the pool like roll into
the water and then roll out of the water
pools heated to 88 degrees year-round
Wow is this a hot tub to its name that's
the hot tub back here we have nine holes
of mini putt-putt golf this is a mini
golf course which is odd but cool I
guess I love mini golf do you really I
do
that's really funny because you're a
very large human being so excited to
just get back out in the links you know
see if I still got it
really better yes this is gonna be a
competitive week
yeah we're gonna have so many things to
we're gonna keep a running tally who's
gonna win which we bet so Nikki in my
relationships and basically the
strongest point it's ever been this
mentioned so big that I don't think
we're even gonna see each other that
much I don't think it's really gonna
bring our relationship closer together
it's probably just gonna keep it where
it is I think we're both gonna find what
we need in this mansion because it has
everything he wants with activities and
it has everything that I want with
relaxation and luxury if I run into her
by the pool then I'll say hi but well
alright a great time thank you so much
well see how we well done and feel free
to call or text me if you have any
questions I'm kind of frozen
if choice you want to let's just go this
knife I'm going to take six hours this
weekend sleep I mean I kind of want the
big bedroom and of course I want
everyone to think that dream um I'd say
we should play foosball for it but your
fingers broken
I'm gonna handicap can you do that I
mean will you fit in the other beds of
course not
I don't know okay I'm going to take a
shower in your bathroom fine right now
no master bedroom for me
yeah well I guess every room is fine
hey I'm little progress and my own T me
[Music]
yeah fancy people who live in homes like
this like we're they even do with their
time yeah it's not about the bedroom
right it's about all the activities
outside
we should get massages I don't like
massages what I don't like I don't like
being like touch I think it doesn't but
I don't like massages special built in
racks for my pants it's a good life just
I got plenty of time before the daytime
so I'm gonna play a little bit how many
go I don't know anything
[Music]
eyeballs in the mini golf by myself it's
fun but like there's something kind of
sad about mini golfing by yourself I'm
starting to get the hang of like how to
operate the house it's bathtime so let's
see how this baby works oh I don't know
how to turn off all the lights in this
place like I don't think I ever will
turn them off the house is so big the
only thing is that it's like a little
spooky because I'm alone Nicky and I
spent most the day exploring like
different parts of the house in the
backyard in the front yard and
everything we didn't actually end up
seeing much of each other from once the
times Garrett and I have been roommates
I'm always like just hoping for a little
bit of client time and a little bit of
like private space here I have like all
of the private space I ever needed we
did a lot of like very nice opulent
lifestyle stuff today tomorrow it's
gonna be over-the-top I think he's got
the masseuse going and
we've got chef oh it's gonna be awesome
maybe like even like we'll get sick of
each other by the end of tomorrow good I
need you morning of the second day it
looks nice out I have to go to the
bathroom
alright that's another bathroom down wow
look at the steam coming off the pool Oh
today's gonna be a great day thanks for
coffee mm-hmm let's make some eggs juicy
a cutting board anywhere no that's a
problem is that we don't know where
anything is it's too big
where are the utensils around the other
side of the island this is a huge island
it seemed a very long time to get around
just yellow where's my coffee
everything's so far away what do you
want to do that mmm would you reduce
some minigolf yeah I'll put a little bit
yesterday and then we should swim yeah
this just feels like we're a very
unhappily married couple it's more or
less what the series is okay so the star
competition begins golf what do you want
to bet um like 20 bucks $20 were rich
now to 150 I'll do $50 what are that
games are we playing horseshoes and
pickleball ball maybe like free throws I
don't know how to play basketball the
perfect okay but I have a handicap so
you also need a handicap so give me your
pinkie ibises do anything for you
it holds my knuckle in place okay all
right let's pick our clubs
how does mini golf work I'm gonna win
$150 I gotta play regular golf
do you play golf regularly nope
not anymore but you did yeah so if you
make this we go into sin death if you
miss I win okay thank you one game to
zero it's like we're getting pretty
close $150
game number two free throws so I guess
my first one to five free throws wins
okay this is gonna be pretty
embarrassing for me
[Music]
okay so this is really working so me I
guess just the first person to make it
let's say it first wasn't make - okay -
instead of five instead of five we
should you - and then you made to neuro
what the hell okay
I don't know fun horseshoes I have to go
what where the Dickies massage is here
so I have to go let them in and set up
for a massage I was gonna take a shower
in your room I can't figure it out
surprise it's a massage that's why I'm
not getting one but you are hi I'm Jenna
nice to meet you yeah yeah I don't
that's why I ordered it for you enough
for me well thank you yeah okay
I think he's getting her massage don't
want to do all these dishes I am here
and I'm naked and I'm getting a surprise
massage from Garrett
so the nicest roommate thing he's ever
done
okay you guys know that's the water it's
so nice
thank you for letting my socks was
amazing yeah was it good
yeah it's great oh you feel so good
[Music]
hello hey got your drinks ready for you
well I have a fairly simple firm we're
having a private chef come pretty
exciting
we're gonna have some strawberry basil
sea scallops with a strawberry basil
salsa we're gonna have a cucumber you
log which is your solid tonight we're
gonna have lamb lamb 1 and then we're
also gonna have wild rice and we're
gonna have the service and design it's
gonna be a chocolate lava cake raspberry
compote and vanilla ice cream
wow that smells great I'm gonna go get
dinner ready guys I guess we were used
all right
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
we look fancy we did [ __ ] fancy I'll
wait for fancy dinner oh hi welcome to
dinner thank you thank you oh thank you
our fancy dining room oh okay it's very
good mm-hmm
we're rich now - good hell yes that's
what we're always toasting to - good
health good health we've conquered
everything else all that's left is good
help good help
right well don't have to do fancy things
to whine you've already screwed it up of
course we have scouts mr. baseball this
awesome thank you outside in outside
enjoy them but that's a salad fork this
is not a salad that's true so skip that
salad for it
when in doubt pinky out oh this feels
dumb being this far away yeah you're
using I feel like we're at a board
meeting yeah do you wanna move over
there over here foods like present here
it's in here decorum be damned there was
my thought dinner was unbelievable it
was really nice to just like get dressed
up for a fancy dinner and sit next to
each other and have really great food
it's like being at a restaurant for
yourself
chef Michael was so attentive to just
like us I think we both enjoyed the
property more with each other than we
did on our own on that first day do you
want to play air hockey in these fancy
clothes
oh we played a lot of games today I'm
barely in it with that air hockey win
got two more games to play tomorrow
maybe I will not lose 150 dollars but
maybe I will I spend so much more time
with Nicky today it was so much more fun
I think I'm starting to figure out that
mansions are great because you can fit
more people that you love in them while
it is fun to enjoy on your own today I
think was really really fun spending it
with Garret she's got to win both of our
challenges tomorrow I don't think she's
gonna do it oh it says master suite is
still pretty sweet oh no morning of the
third day my head is killing me
wine is the worst good morning good
morning you may finish this we have
lived in a mansion for three days and
man it was action-packed fifty dollars
this mansion was really really great to
experience and I definitely come back
but I don't know if I would live in a
mansion oh right that's two games to two
pickleball kind of like tennis but
smaller it's so big and there's so much
to do but I don't need this much space
poor - good point
I think if I lived in a mansion every
day the appeal would kind of wear off it
kind of makes you think twice about
really like what you need in a home if
we can put a shower like they have here
into a smaller house that's the idea
living situation my apartment in LA is a
fraction the size of
this property sometimes that can feel
like a really really small place but at
the same time it's got everything I need
also my wife is their best brother
mansion wasn't like the enormous kitchen
or it wasn't even a shower it was like
when Nicky and I were hanging out
enjoying all this space together we had
no obstacles right with all this space
and all these things to do we like still
through like a bet in there to make us
sort of compete but I think it brought
us closer together hundred fifty dollars
and I brought my bank account closer to
solvency so mansions are great when you
can fill them with people that you love
and have a great time with them other
than that do we really need that much to
live I don't think I do
okay by mansion my mansion in cactus
okay that theater room though no it was
cool I like the inner rooms
[Music]